AS WE GO TO OUR NEXT
GAME, COMPANY DICNIC.
I HAVE TO SAY, IT'S LIKE
ONE OF MY FAVORITE THINGS
THAT ARE YOU CHEERING FOR
SOMETHING AND YOU HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT COMPANY DICNIC IS.
BRING IT ON!
IT'S A DICNIC!
I DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND OF
[BLEEP] JOB YOU HAVE, BUT
ARE YOU GETTING INVITES FOR
SPRING COOKOUT, BUT REDDIT
USER NO WORRY POSTED AN
E-MAIL INVITATION SENT BY
THEIR HR DEPARTMENT.
CLEARLY A WOMAN IN HR
GOOGLED GUY IN HAWAIIAN
SHIRT, WHAT SHE ENDED UP
WITH WAS THIS --
THE HEDGEHOG, RON JEREMY, IN A
HAWAIIAN SHIRT.
THIS PICNIC IS GOING TO BE
A SAUSAGEFEST.
YOUR JOB IS TO LIST AS
MANY RON JEREMY-SANCTIONED
MENU ITEMS AS POSSIBLE.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK, GO.
MIKE LAWRENCE.
>> FIVE DOLLAR FOOT LONG.
>> POINTS.
ARDEN.
[BLEEP]STICKERS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
GUY.
>> HAWAIIAN DONKEY PUNCH.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
MIKE.
>> RON JEREMISU.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
GUY.
>> GAPE JUICE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
ARDEN.
-- OH MY GOD.
IT'S NOT JUST A PLAY ON
WORDS, IT'S A STUNNING
VISUAL.
ARDEN.
>> CALIFORNIA GLORY ROLE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
MIKE.
>> ANACONDIMENTS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
MIKE.
>> BABY-BACK RIBBED FOR HER
PLEASURE.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. ARDEN.
>> CIRCLE JERK CHICKEN.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
GUY.
>> ROOT BEER SCROTS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS,
MIKE.
>> FLAN JEREMY.
>> CHRIS: POINTS!